now the Pentagon is saying that 50 US
troops in Iraq have been diagnosed with
traumatic brain injuries after the
Iranian missile strikes earlier this
month on the military facility where
they were based the u.s. originally said
that nobody had been hurt in the strikes
that were in retaliation for the u.s.
assassination of Qasem Soleimani of
course that top Iranian commander last
week though the Pentagon said 34 people
had been injured and that some was still
receiving treatment right we can speak
to Richard Weitz now who's a security
and defense analyst at Wicky strut a
global risk consultancy he's joining us
from Washington DC and Richard thanks
for talking to us traumatic brain
injuries it sounds really serious yes
and this is something that we become
aware of in both civilian and military
life over the past years has become much
clearer how even small concussion can
over time really and seriously impact a
person's health and so I think it's you
know I think this is something that the
military is going to respond pretty
extensively for terms of reach so do you
think do you think that these injuries
then were not apparent at the time when
Donald Trump tweeted that everything was
well it was all good and said that
nobody had been hurt in those Iranian
missile strikes
sure I mean at the time we were feared
that their missiles would kill other US
soldiers or Iraqi soldiers or civilians
or there'd be a lot of serious physical
injuries which would be apparent in in
terms whereas these kind of injuries are
really they take a while to become
visible it's the kind of test you have
to do would bring them out but you
wouldn't you wouldn't necessarily see
that immediate attacks I think that was
probably why the initial assessment was
that there were no serious casualties
and we're seeing this continually upward
revision in the number of those people
who are affected by potential
drama entries but you can probably
understand that this will cause many
people to again doubt the word of the
president if not the Pentagon as well I
mean a whole sort of fact-checking
industry has grown up under the
presidency of Donald Trump right that
president is not alone in underestimate
impact of these I mean it's I think for
many years a lot of us just didn't
didn't really understand how serious
these were and we've seen a lot of
corrective efforts both within the
military and in terms of sports
activities limiting the age in which you
can participate contact sports making
people wear helmets and so on so I think
you know this is something that people
have been criticizing President Trump
for if this is not this is a common
problem that we're gonna need a lot more
education and understanding of Richard
Weitz thank you very much indeed talking
just live from Washington thank you